and now I want to tell you about today's
guest look I've been a fan of this guy
for so long I actually have a confession
that I need to make to him he has dates
coming up in Colorado Springs Boise
Idaho Spokane Washington Huntington New
York and Tuscaloosa Alabama he has so
many comedy specials out he is he's
beloved I think that's to say the least
but who is he I don't know honestly he
and I have never even spoken before but
he's here today to talk about his new
film where he is playing a dramatic role
in a dark movie called American dreamers
that comes out in November and also to
take us through another round of our
March Madness state Wars
let's keep it moving thank you guys for
all the contributions ladies and
gentlemen and others mr. Jim Gaffigan
[Music]
Jim Gaffey that Gaffey taffy and how's
that going
okay this is a new book out about greg
Giraldo yeah there is I haven't read it
yeah well you know I mean I was
interviewing I did know him so what's
the book gonna do for you well you know
if anything there's something weird also
is you have friends like there's a
certain part like when you have buddies
mm-hmm and you kind of discover that
they have other buddies there's a little
bit of like what are you doing what are
you cheating on me
so like you know my relationship with
Greg was I mean when I started I hung
out with him when I met him we were both
like wearing suits in this fish
restaurant and doing stand-up with a lot
of mental was Bob zany conference no it
was no this was back when you were in
New York there was this place this
legendary woman Gladys who ran a comedy
club and and she had won at this fish
restaurant and used to pay to go on Wow
and that's where I met greg Giraldo and
he and he was when he was doing he's
wearing a suit as well he was a lawyer
and I was like I worked in advertising
and both our family like his parents
were immigrants and my father was like
the first one to go to college so it was
kind of like we used to joke around it's
like you know all the sacrifice of our
generations and we're like you know
telling stupid jokes
it's like general like my kind of my
family's been in this country forever
and it's just like my dad was like the
first one to go to college and now I'm
like you know I'm gonna I'm gonna do
stand-up in a fish restaurant we're have
to pay it doesn't make any sense that's
whatever uh it's so you know I was
thinking I was actually talking to my
brother yesterday about like some
generations of families like take an L
for the next generation oh that's
interesting
it's like you know like like my mom was
like a hard worker she had worked so
hard and now like I've had to work hard
but it's like I get to at least be able
to like tell jokes and not have to like
deliver newspapers it's like you know
it's like some some generations just
take that they just take the loss for
the next one
ya know you see that and
immigrants all the time yeah it's a lot
really smart driven people in there and
that's then they look at their kids
really you're going to med school right
and they're like I guess so yeah so like
you sure as hell I can say you're not
working as varo that's for sure Daniel I
we can talk about this because we're
both Asian so yeah so this is this is
like a meeting of white trash you and I
right there's a little bit of like it's
uh you know like it's interesting I
don't know you at all yes but I think
like being kind of like I'm from Indiana
you're from Louisiana
yeah there's you know there's it's like
there's a groundedness that I think but
you know here we are in LA in New York
in LA that even though I've lived in New
York for thirty years it's like I still
watch the news and I'll see how some
things are playing out and I'll be like
you know where I grew up they're not
gonna take it that way yeah you know
what yeah no that's not gonna happen
yes that's the same they're not they're
not that impressed by that in fact that
will make people angry and it's weird
like but I have children and I'm like
raising them as New Yorkers so I know
I'm there I'm gonna stop the the chain
of trash I guess Wow it's that it's
called recycling it's recycling right
that's crazy man
but who knows I miss you out like one
thing I noticed like I was singing the
other day like things you can do when
you're poor and things you do like poor
people like we would always burn stuff
in the ditch you know and we would play
this game called dark bandits we would
get water all over us or soda and they
would jump through the smoke of the fire
until it like covered our and now like
they you know some people doing
blackface we weren't making it a racial
thing Buddha's jumping through the fire
we're like kind of like grayed out you
know that's that's and were you guys
done drugs you're just doing I mean just
know we didn't even have adolescents in
it so this is pre pubis you know we were
just jumping through that cuz you know
me just burn [ __ ] in the yo ya know the
burning of leaves I remember that smell
just burning burning anything I remember
there used to be a lot more possible
dead bodies when I was growing
like I remember like walking home one
time with my brother who was kind of he
was like he still is a year older than
me and I was walking home with him and
we were like on the beach of Lake
Michigan and there was this there was
this hump and we're like what is that
what is it and it was like a body that's
awesome and so we started walking up and
then the body moved and my brother ran
off just leaving me in the dust I could
have died yeah I thought you know like
and when you're like a ten year old boy
you're like that's probably a zombie
yeah my brother didn't care and well he
ran ahead
you know what college no he ran ahead to
just wherever our homework oh god it's a
great story I got a lot more of I liked
this bracket up there well look it's
funny you're here man because I think
especially like the way that times are
now with the news thinking that most of
America is you know some ways and just
the disconnection that's out there yeah
that we're headed back towards state
governments you know which I would love
to see you know
oh that's interest um so we started this
past weekend state Wars March Madness a
couple of oh I can't see that far but
what does it say
so it would be stayed on state fights it
would be yes stay on state battles and
it's no it's more battles we say cuz
it's not we don't you know we're not
trying to condone anybody running out of
their house and you know we're just
talking about it planting the idea well
would it be great if ten years from now
this is a reference point used on the
very new rider just talked about these
these dangerous creative people it is
interesting that we even live in an age
we're like you know joking around about
something like this we have to
consciously be like you know we might
get in trouble for this yeah but all
right so these state rivalries because I
feel you know growing up and is that
Indiana hmm Indiana still in it they're
in this and this is a sweet 16 wearing
right now Nick okay so women so why
would Indiana have a chance against
Illinois well that's how that's what you
and I are here to discuss for any good
game and we're gonna be are each up
where we're at and look a lot of callers
have come in we've had three rounds so
far we had jo koy came in did
Bryan Callen stood around and maybe
bargatze all right who's your son he is
my son
yeah it's my son he's part of the there
should be like a union of trash
comedians or just regular comedians like
it's almost becoming though that like
the outliers are becoming the
disconnected people are starting to be
like I'm grateful at least I have a
connection to humanity or once I like I
feel like I'm in that like I understand
both sides of it right now I know you're
saying you know what's weird is also I
feel as though there is this groundswell
of UFC and you know the the fighting
world of like like you're you're in it
too
and I feel like I'm like I don't know if
I can get in that kind of shape like you
know like there's just the fighters
they're like you know what I like to do
fight and I'm like really do I have to
do that I mean I'm kind of you know I
probably feel more comfortable you know
doing math and reading poetry but can I
do neither I could see you beat somebody
how could she be greg Giraldo I have I
have a temper but you know I'm just I
don't have the energy I just but I don't
know if Indiana as much as I love I grew
up
despising growing up in Indiana really I
used to think like I remember looking
around and going there has been a
mistake I'm not supposed to be here and
I grew up what's amazing about where I
grew up which is the Calumet region this
is gonna be so boring for everyone and
maybe there's someone from Northwest
Indiana you have to understand Northwest
Indiana
first of all Indiana is a is is it's the
most northern southern state like it
geographically it doesn't make sense
Illinois is very kind of Midwestern yes
Indiana is some Midwest but you go to
southern Ohio and people people are
going y'all you know like it's very
southern and so like Indiana is also a
state that was but like you know
Northwest Indiana where I'm from is
it's like the like the it's like the the
people that would commute to Chicago or
like there yes we shall walk Mishawaka a
little bit they it's the industrial
Midwest right and so it's the Rust Belt
oh yeah ten you know where people you
know we're you know like if they use
this cute term like a rasp out when it's
like just economic devastation where it
just makes people very angry they're
like my grandfather owned a house in a
summer house but now I'm working in a
Kmart what is going on even if Kmart's
open I don't know but uh it's a while
it's kind of the new Wild West is like
them wild Midwest it is it's you know
but there's Indiana was always like a
like I have jokes about this when I
perform in Chicago where I tell people
I'm from Indiana and they're like
where's that and you're like 10 minutes
away like it's right there and people
like oh that's because people will drive
through Indiana to go to vacation it's
the Palestine it's basically it's kind
of the white it's like yes Palast its
Palestine it is Palestine and so I don't
know population-wise Indiana over Hill
or wise Gary and I don't know who he is
but this dude is cute yeah yeah anyway
oh this year does he Oh Gary when I was
growing up I worked on the train station
one summer really they built the train
station for the South Shore Railroad I
just got a job you know like a summer
job because you a condescending employee
I could see you being no no I was I was
I was going to college and I had to kind
of hide that I was going to college
I worked in a grocery store one summer
and then I worked like in a steel mill
which is like there weren't many jobs so
like I was lucky it was because my dad
got me in the job was it funny like
where there's some cool stuff about it
cuz you said like you don't like it but
it seemed like to me there's nothing
like I used to work on a farm there was
nothing like going home after work like
it's actually fell asleep under that
dryer and pine over and you don't you
and appreciate lunch oh you're like one
tomato like mixing cement I remember
mixing cement next to a big like smelter
you know where they melt them that oh it
was like so hot and you're just like
what is going on here people would heat
up their lunch on like just benches
because the benches would be so warm
they're like you know melt the cheese of
my sandwich but this is like totally I
also don't want to be like look I did it
for two months I'm not like you know
right but you did it yeah
but Indiana it's you know it's there's
something kind of really kind of like
it's like in the 30s yeah 40s it still
holds on to that stuff I was a wrestler
in high school and before matches people
would say Jesus has already decided
who's won this match oh wow and and you
know like they would afterwards they
would try and save you I was you know
Catholic and they'd be like you know
papist not a lot of Catholics in high
school in Northwest Indiana because it
was where farmland hit Rust Belt so
there was one weekend when I was in high
school and by the way so Chicago is 20
minutes away and I'd be like let's go to
Chicago and everyone's like nah I don't
want to pay for parking and it's like
we'd stay and I remember one weekend I
went to a party in a trailer home mm-hmm
and then the next night I sat on a bale
of hay and I was like looking at like
the lights of Chicago and I was like why
don't we go there why don't they like me
I don't want to go there yeah it's like
you know but oh you were talking I don't
want to pay for parking but somebody
that's our whole life they said that vow
yeah and but but Gary growing up Gary
was the murder capital and there were
always stories of like prom night
someone would get lost and get murdered
like that was also I think that was like
urban legend that was also kind of like
carrying the white kids yeah don't go in
there don't go in and when I was growing
up there were never even off ramps to
identify that it was Gary allow that old
trick because they didn't want people to
say you're a nerd and by the way I
worked there one summer and there were
great people they were great I mean yeah
well they had a guy to saw on the news
who they tried to catch a bullet in his
mouth and shot his own head off actually
and this was like two weeks ago and
Gary's a lot of murders they're not a
crazy novel 1937 Gary was Time
Magazine's most beautiful city in the
world Wow swear to God unbelievable but
it could be the comeback kid that's the
thing it's like what do you think
happens to some of these cities like
that that were kind of like depleted by
like the under stria revolution kind of
when everything has gone more tech and a
lot of like you know we started buying
so many things cheaper abroad yeah I
don't think happens I mean look we've
seen I mean I'm older than you by a
hundred years no but I I see that like
like when I was a little kid Detroit was
like a top-five City yeah it was like up
there with it wasn't Chicago wasn't New
York or wasn't that life but it was
Detroit there's like the black Singapore
almost and it was it was a real-deal
thing and it's like it just went off a
cliff but even you know my dad worked in
a bank in Northwest Indiana and he you
know was like oh it's coming back it's
coming back and you're like you know
like I used to walk to like this one job
and I'm like well there's not people
have left and then I don't know I try I
had this idea for a movie about a guy
coming back to like save this rock and I
think like the Pete Buddha judge I think
he talks a little bit
it sounds very familiar like being from
the Rust Belt kind of like this
practicality of making sense about some
of this stuff but then again you know
it's not like
South Bend is this miracle right it's
like if you've been to South Bend it's a
great city but there's parts of it where
you're like whoa
yes what happened yeah really bent yeah
I yeah I remember going to mr. walk a
funny bone there back in a day and some
guys smoked cigars one of the first guys
ever opened up for and we had to share
was like a comedy condo and I said I can
you not smoke cigars inside is this free
it was five below outside yeah and he
said I'm a smoker and so the whole
weekend I was just sitting there just
breathing cigar smoke you probably
smoked 40 cigars you know what I think I
think you know like even hearing you
talk about that and that's also why I
love comedians is that you're thrust
into these situations that I think most
people construct their lives to make it
easier yeah and I think with comedians
you're kind of thrust into those comedy
condo situations or just like brutal
experiences you want the weirdness look
I did a show in Poughkeepsie which is
not a bad town but we're dry were it's
coming back right no we're driving
through there I was with a you know some
guy he was driving and we saw and I was
like oh my god there's a fight over
there and and there was a fight between
this two guys on the street it was like
I was June I'm like all right that's I
was like that's weird and then we were
driving to the comedy club and then I
saw two women fight oh yeah and you're
like two fights the same half-hour they
were related yeah they were just like
it's like but that's what's going on
yeah people are living that's what's
going on like there's just like I don't
know if it was a bad day for Pepsi and
because he's a nice town look it I mean
that's it but I see I love like
sometimes I feel like out here in these
coasts man you just get so everything so
just weak you know there's no chance of
dying there's no chance of like then a
strong wind pulls a piece of sheet metal
through your [ __ ] cousin's neck you
know I'm saying there's no [ __ ] glory
I'm saying there's no there's no chance
that your buddy loses his life to oh you
know astray you know piece of sheetrock
on a jobsite today you know there's just
no there's no it's weird because the
harumph it's kind of it when you come
it's like oh yeah jack you let your
body's like the seaming comes and kind
of looks out that's why you're saying
that I have seen drawings of it yeah
well anyway Chris Farley do you know
that oh I didn't know that people think
it's Donald Trump or me it is Chris
Farley yeah that's interesting
went to my high school for a half a year
did he really kick that I think for like
yeah for flashing where was not the
other day and somebody said he went to
the bathroom it was like a dinner
function and he came back completely
naked it to his chair but you know
what's weird is when I was when I first
moved to New York I would go back home
and people be like how'd you get that
and and or they would be like you know
that's a bad idea and like there was
like when I first moved in New York I
was like what am i doing
and now New York is night and now it's
inverted you know it's like New York is
safer than Poughkeepsie yeah sure I mean
like there's been this inverse oh yeah
like in LA you know the story was like
people showing up getting off the bus
and then their prostitute yeah yeah so
you got to be careful you got to be male
to do that now I mean used to be at
least female right now you got to be a
young male we got to keep this guy in
the office Gianni's Ansem yeah he's
doing a lot of hockey so they call it
these boys all right now a little lean
I'm sorry which state wins
yep we're gonna decide you mean it and a
lot of our audience is decided to I
watched half of your new movie I want to
talk oh that right good yeah yeah
congratulations thank you it's fun stuff
it's fun stuff did you know first of all
I had two questions one where was it
shot that was shot at Norfolk
and if it's that if it's the one where
I'm like the uber driver right yeah
dream I'm the American dreamer American
dreamer yeah
and that's coming out when I think in
November but that's one of those where
yeah it gets pretty dark at the end I've
only seen half and I don't want to know
that yeah yeah no it's good it's good
it's one of those because you know I
love acting but you'll do some stuff and
you'll see it you know the finished
product you're like no okay cuz it's
hard and it's hard also as a comedian
because we have so much when you go
onstage you live or die by what you do
right and but ya know it's fun doing the
acting thing I mean norfolk's no joke it
opens September 20th by the way
Norfolk is not is definitely no joke I
was in a nightclub there with Anthony
Anderson at 2:00 a.m. and that fleece
was going off dude I mean it was like
little sigh year up in there
Wow and uh he ordered some fish fillets
and they got delivered over the top of
the crowd was like 300 people maybe 600
people dancing and an order of fish
fillets fried catfish filets came over
the crowd wait a minute so what were you
doing with and what were you doing there
we were doing a charity show this guy
Pharrell yeah I know Metro wants his
ashy hands
well it's good detail is he but because
he's from there there's a lot of like
musicians from there Timberland yeah
yeah Farrelly yeah yeah very rough hands
like he could DJ um he could DJ a chess
set out of a piece of wood you know I'm
saying remix huh he's got very uh he
might have a little bit of uh reptile in
him right very big but uh but anyway
yeah I love his hits and I'm yeah but
anyway meeting at the answer order some
fish in this beautiful nightclub and i
was fun it was fun yeah we're doing a
charity show down there with me and him
in Gary Owen the white cat Williams they
call him yeah seems like his pale is me
oh he is oh he is my Italian yeah I
always won
be Italian or maybe Hispanic I'd like to
be Hispanic oh you're the Spanish Gary
oh I'm the Spanish Gary Owens but no I
want to know a little bit more on the
set did you what is it what's like a
number one thing you've learned about
acting that you didn't maybe expect is
that so much of it is just not acting
it's like you know it's it sounds so
corny but it is just like being uh you
know just being authentic which is the
same stand-up it's like you know
stand-up you tell you know you tell a
story for the 50th time you have to be
authentic in how you tell it and
understand those points and so I mean
they're very different skill sets but
you know it's acting's really fun it's
fun particularly if you're like in that
movie I start off one way and I end up
completely different in the movie saying
about a lot of different things and you
cannot identify with the frustration
because I think comedians eat so much
[ __ ] that when someone's going through
it we can kind of identify mm-hmm that's
interesting
yeah yeah you Kim you're a reader of
that sometimes like even when I'm on
stage I'll notice um look out over the
crowd like yes I'm entertaining them but
sometimes I'll go into a mode even
against my own desire where I'm kind of
I guess in auto mode at some moments but
I'm you can tell what's going on with
almost everybody in the crowd I feel
like oh it's fascinating like this
person's upset this this relationships
not going to work out there on the
second day they're trying she's
something sad she's somethings made her
very sad
yeah it's do you feel that no I you know
like I have this inside voice where I
sometimes talk for people in the
audience and some of it is also you can
interpret stuff that's not necessarily
there yeah I don't know about you but
like I you know I think that a lot of
comedians have like you got to read
situations you know like even when like
a comedian gets off and has another
comedian they're decent you know it's
like that's important information agree
or they're really fun
and if that real fun for that comedian
sometimes that means they're horrible
they're like they're really fun for you
oh [ __ ] I'm gonna hate that feel like if
Neal Brennan says they're a little wild
then I know it's gonna be a blast for me
right no it's different things like it's
but so yeah there's I don't know it's
all I see a map of men is that Wisconsin
oh yeah yeah there you go
yeah he's it was constant I'd uh Nick
was he's a premature baby and look how
far he's come now and he's come a long
way very long very oh yeah what were we
talking about before I'm like it's like
this is so fun it's like I just kind of
go off on tangents yeah it doesn't
matter that's the best thing about this
this job is that we don't really know
sometimes what we're doing oh here's
what I was gonna say when we were
talking about struggles of you know like
kind of eating [ __ ] like I was talking
to my 13 year old son can you believe it
I have a 13 year old I know I was like a
child bride and but I and he more or
less communicated to me like what you
get everything works out for you
like he doesn't realize that you know
like we were before we started you're
like I didn't know I'd be doing a
podcast like you don't know it's like
you know like there's a lot of failure
and a lot of awkwardness that I think
that so I don't know how I'm trying to
communicate that to my children like you
gotta like you got to fall in your face
a lot now just find something you like
do you start to worry that your children
are gonna be that kind of I worry that
one day I will have children that are
the kids that I didn't like growing up
because I thought because my financial
means will change in my lifetime yeah
what's that been like uh you know I'm
not know I mean I'm definitely conscious
of it and but my wife is very much of
the opinion like we're not gonna raise
douchebags right but and we're a very
sarcastic household you know and we're
like humors important and orgasm helps
threatening you know it's good you know
it's like sometimes the six-year-old
doesn't get
but but no that is an interesting thing
so like you know I also like have more
or less said to them like I remember my
son who's now 13 like he was like seven
he's like I'm just gonna live with you
guys the rest of my life yeah like
there's not gonna be any money left like
I told him like tickets there's no money
like I'm more or less you know but I
think you have to create this this kind
of belief that like yeah I'm not gonna
give you anything
yeah so that they'll go off and do it
but I don't know I don't think any
parents really are sure what they're
doing well somebody said I heard you got
too invested in water parks or something
was that you really yeah
no I don't know sometimes have you ever
had someone go hey you did that joke in
the early I don't even remember doing
that yeah oh we do this probably a good
time I thought about this dude I did
want it when I first started out I did
one of your jokes I didn't have any
material and I've seen her on television
I wanna apologize honestly what joke was
that um I mean it was your Hot Pockets
joke and I think College that's all
right and I'm sorry man and I also did
some of them while I'm at it also did
some of us Cedric entertainers material
um and you yours did better I will say
that but I am sorry man I never did it
sense and this was probably fourteen
years ago I've never new material and I
got booked
yeah and how how long are you were doing
great you were doing good you've been
doing it probably maybe nine months I
bought a booth at NACA and sold a bill
of goods that I couldn't you know that I
couldn't back off uh-huh
but I remember doing a man and it felt
good too I will say that part yeah and
it's weird like when you cuz I'm sorry
that's all right when when some when you
hear like about stuff like that because
sometimes it's just honest overlap you'd
think and you know like by the way Joe
Rogan he's kind of like the police force
of comedy which is great yeah but I
always kind of have the idea of like
because there's to rip there's like some
people that are really [ __ ] derivative
and you're like all right but yeah
they're not gonna come up with more yeah
I mean like right there yeah they're
just riding it's almost a tributary an
offshoot of yeah it's
I mean I think that stand-up is kind of
an ongoing thing and it's constructed on
self-assignment so you have to keep
moving and recreating and improving
yourself I say that and then people just
want to hear the hot pocket joke right
yeah I'm sorry I brought him up it was
jealous that's when I needed something
you were there for me is this little
roar or garrick is this is this one of
your sponsors my friend Brad he just is
this is his company but it's not a
sponsor even though they should be
always drinking is it it's just he has
his own water where does he make it in
this like shed or something
he's in like this is my friend Brad
they're actually killing it there and
like thousands of stores now so yeah so
they're doing well enough to friggin pay
us yes for sure that's true dude they
had a guy armor when I was growing up
speaking of rare things which nobody
mentioned they had a guy who made his
son a wooden shirt in my in our
neighborhood made him a wooden shirt out
of like a pot of it I would think would
good call yeah like a thin plywood not
the night you know it wasn't like teak
or anything and what was that for for
Christmas for Christmas so wooden shoes
no like regular shoes so regular shoes
but like we know about wooden shoes like
he wasn't Dutch or something no no they
weren't Dutch they were local and they
dad was Alvis impersonator and he'd been
at hit by see how do you say that like
there's a bunch of them you know like
he's one of those Elvis impersonator
there's not a lot of them like you know
like every town has the Elvis
impersonator well this is ours
I think per capita we had a pretty good
amount thank you but the t-shirt and so
did the fat Center she made it as that
was an alcoholic and I remember it was
like Christmas Eve and he was trying to
find something to make that's not a big
surprise finding out so like and I
helped him say it's like a reverse
Pinocchio like he's like saying I want
you it should be wood so I'm gonna make
a wood shirt that's a was it a one-piece
like was it was it kind of like you
slide in on yeah it wasn't I think it
was kind of like a box more but it was
very I'd say was form-fitted I tell us
about a medium
so was insert in some ways it was like a
chestplate
yeah yes and you know what's funny is
the kid was the kid used to vomit on the
bus a lot and people would beat him up
for it and now that's that seems like
that's bordering on bullying fair dude
it's a bus ride everybody's on their he
clean it you know and so he's throwing
up and super oh like how dare you that
reminds me of like I had pneumonia and
my my dad used to get mad without cause
I'm like I have pneumonia and he's like
stop coughing but like so he so the the
wooden shirt kid yep in the bus and kids
would beat him at that so the shirt
almost ended up protecting him for a
while so in a weird way it was kind of
like exactly what he needed you know
even though his dad didn't know what his
dad didn't know he was going through
these troubles on the bus because a boy
vd2 ice cream on the way to school and
vomit on the bus because the bus was
real this back on the bus is no shocks
yeah sometimes no wheels I run time
it was just front wheels no wooden
shirts yeah no shirts yeah I mean then
they had a bird but I always try to get
into his shirt I remember at school it
was just a different time man and where
was the wearing Louisiana was this weird
north to New Orleans right about 50
miles long does Jeff functor River
you're from you know Lee Harvey Oswald
went to our middle school that was a big
thing now you mentioned that the Klan
guy your buddies with him David Duke he
was you're lifting partner
we were gym I wouldn't say we were gym
buddies but I would say that we were
lovers
I was is that he's from that neck of the
woods
I got refused from there but yeah we
talked right when you came in I know
Indiana I got a Q gets accused of a
loose
you got the Ku Klux Klan started in the
end of a week and apologized I get some
Murphysboro Tennessee oh really
yeah if we're a real racist you would
know this nobody no I think it is
Murphysboro
but I remember hearing stories that
Indiana the governor used to be picked
by the Klan yeah by the way like you
know obviously I'm against hatred of any
and that no but like the thing is it's
like it is weird that there is like
these these hate group was so acceptable
they thought you know those Klan guys
will pick ya
let them it just seemed so absurd seems
so absurd like just two generations ago
they're like you know the Klan you got
to win over the Klan so you could get to
be governor yeah insane it's just
different times man you know and now
anybody can be a politician which is I
think is awesome I think we're we're two
elections away from having like a pet or
something cool right like just a dog
president a digital some digital
president a tamagotchi that's
interesting like one of those things
that moves like in and I was in Korea in
the airport and there was this thing
going around do computer late do you
want assistance like that could be a
president that would be amazing or we're
heading back to state governments state
governments do you think so I think so
it's just you know by the way it was
only World War one when Americans kind
of gathered around the idea of being
American before it was very much States
well people are losing a little bit of
that spirit like even I went to the UFC
fights this weekend in Atlanta I had
never been right and I mean I was right
there I mean catching if anybody had
AIDS I have it you know so and I'm I
don't mean that I'm just mean now I have
it right you know or it'll show I mean
were you like sitting there like pretty
excited well yeah when I'm excited it
I'm like get a guy like a McDonald you
love the the was seeing the fight in
person like you've done that before
never so it did it transform like you're
like oh I understand it is it like yes
something so incredibly primal that is
it's brave I thought I found it to be
brave right uh I did it I didn't find it
like these are idiot men that are
fighting there's me at the fight trainer
that made it to air
on the on the broadcast am I afraid yeah
and a guy who was on one of a guest on
here one of our first guests actually
one so he won the belt the other night
and oh my god and so and it was amazing
to see he win for his weight class
he won for his way might sound like a
girl did he win like his fighting thing
did he did he find someone no and so you
want it man is it just one is there one
organization it's so weird how like
boxing is just it's not as exciting yeah
it's not feel like I need some kicks
yeah Ronnie kicks or I need I mean we
have the cage element so that changed it
box you can go through the ropes if you
want you know like nobody does but like
no getting out there's no get now no you
hounding people what is the age like
where you're like you know you gotta
pack it in you're like 35 starts there
they start aging out a little bit heavy
weights they usually they last longer
just like in boxing they can go for a
while but yeah 35 you start losing speed
but what I saw that was interesting Jim
was people sometimes there would be
someone from one country and somebody
from another country cheering and it was
interesting to hear people cheer USA
right really and the guy sitting next to
me was like oh man look at these people
are idiots and I was thinking if we if
something American guy was in their
country you don't think with all those
people are gonna be just being like oh
let's welcome the American guy no they
would the fans would be cheering for
their country wasn't an American versus
a foreigner it was an American verse
there was a bunch of different scenarios
oh there's different scenarios yeah yeah
tons there was like America versus
Brazil there was America versus Russia
Poland like um but sometimes it would
the USA chant we'd go out and it was
just interesting was you always rooted
for the white guy I you know what my
twin it's funny I cuz I thought about
that a couple times am I I cheered to
get I cheered for a gas tell Castellon
the Mexican guy it was built like you or
me at the beach bro we were 16 and I
couldn't believe and he was fighting the
tallest leanest Nigerian man you've ever
seen and they just destroy each other
like is it something is some
the appeal like someone could die is
that some of the appeal yeah there was a
couple shots were said if one I'm gonna
hit the other one I've been like that's
that's not a liver nobody's living
through that right this guy on the right
he were beat like swim trunks and he
fought that guy on the left who was way
taller than him and how much do these
guys make for this fight cuz like what I
got paid for fighting but like these
guys are they probably get paid a
hundred thousand for the 500 thousand
hundred thousand maybe yeah the top tier
guys get like two hundred thousand the
champions get like five hundred thousand
but yeah these guys Israel Adesanya and
Kelvin Gastelum probably how often
goodbye five three four times the four
times a year is really really active
considered and two is pretty average and
they probably make money on sponsorship
stuff to wear some but it was
interesting that the UFC kind of owns
them all and I got this weird vibe that
sort of Dana white guy on the side he
gave me like honest a creepy vibe and he
felt a little it was definitely very the
most Fidel Castro type of vibe I'd ever
gotten in my life from so he's kind of a
Vince McMahon yes he's kind of like the
little the the guy but it's but in the
end they get in there and they fight but
it was interesting to see that some
people were like there was a USA vibe at
certain points yeah um which i think is
like there's nothing wrong with like I
agree you know I mean there's a
difference between nationalism like like
let's go invade another country and kind
of you know a certain sense of pride you
know it's like yeah just like we kind of
you know you know being from like these
non kind of coastal states there's a
camaraderie and he's from Wisconsin so
he's trash too he knows
do you I mean like he's got they got
like food there you got food in
Louisiana and Wisconsin there's no food
and Indian yeah that's true mom no
there's not much going on fires fires
then the fire department store in
Indiana the fire department started and
knowing that actually that's interesting
I could see that I guess yeah but I know
that like the Hoosier oh yeah that was
all about
when they opened because again you know
Indiana was I think this is what I was
told that it was like land set aside for
natives similar to Oklahoma and being
white people they're like yeah we
changed our mind then they let people in
but there were still some Indians there
and so they would be very suspicious
when they would hear someone they'd go
who's there who's there
yeah and that's supposedly was your
started oh I don't know or someone told
me that and I look like a fool
whoo yeah yeah well we had on the chip
funky River which was named after the
defunct Indian somebody said that how
they got their name was somebody took a
huge rock and threw it in the river and
the sound of me when it went in was just
boom oh my gosh that's amazing that's
amazing we believe that oh so were there
what was I want to know what the
audience was like at the fight mostly
male mostly male yep um a lot of like it
was there very diverse our own
testosterone II as you would think it
was like was there a gambling vibe or
was it kind of like no it didn't have
that Vegas vibe because it was in
Atlanta this would this every every time
they're in a different city kind of in
this championship was in Atlanta I
thought there was a lot of diversity in
the audience you know it was all I would
say maybe ten percent female and 90%
male where there's some female fights
there was one one on this card and it
was interesting so I don't like watching
women fight you know at my core and I'm
okay with that I don't think it's you
know I'll watch a woman you know
you know lap dance yeah but it's like
well it's interesting I've never seen it
you're I mean I mean I've never I mean I
can see I saw it but like I've never
really so but it's a little upsetting to
you to me when you lose your erection
yeah
what what is so did they start with that
like the the you knew the guy that was
that the final fight yeah how many
fights were there there were sixteen
fights thirty
13:15 we started I got there 5 p.m. and
we were there until 1:30 in the morning
oh wow and it was a long time anyway so
people are kind of like boozing it up
yeah people are booze and people are
some people taking cigarette break stuff
like that yeah one guy kept yelling
trying to get my attention the whole
fight they call me the Rat King sometime
and his fellow just kept with literally
I don't think he saw one fight he stood
Tim Fodor for me and yelled rat King the
whole time oh you know what I got I got
a story to tell you
so I'm from Indiana right yeah I keep
bringing this up so when like the Colts
weren't even there like I had already
like like left college or whatever the
Colts moved from Baltimore to
Indianapolis and Peyton Manning has run
I'm like enjoying the Colts
so then the Colts go to the very their
very first Super Bowl and the the owners
the Earth's haze were very nice they're
like we want all Indiana people to come
back John Mellencamp all these people
and they're like we want you to perform
them like this is amazing so I go back I
perform they win the Super Bowl and so
then two years go by then they go back
to the Super Bowl and it was when they
were playing the same yeah and it was
like also like it was this Saint season
and people from Indiana are like
generally kind of like like even when I
would go to a Colts game they're like
those Eagles fans are obnoxious and I'm
like yeah I know because I live in the
Northeast now right and so but so I'm at
the Superbowl
the culture playing the Saints I'm
wearing a Colt at because I'm a guest of
the Colts hmm and somebody called you
the n-word no all these Saints fans were
yelling like it was it was like just
watched the game but like these people
they had never it's like had you guys
ever been outside before like it was the
Superbowl
they were the most drum
I've ever seen yeah they were like it
was the wedding it was VE Day VJ Day it
was and it was just one of those things
where I was like I can't take this hat
off because I don't want to be dishonest
but like just it was just like it was
like Andrew Jackson was just tearing
apart the White House it was insane it
was fastening it I was like oh my god
and and this in I live in New York and
like a Jets fans you know like I've been
to a Jets game with my kids and I'm like
we're not going over there cuz there's
guys yelling yeah there's a misguided
alcoholic Saints have a little bit more
rhythm of its when you pull a horn out
somebody won't pull a baby out of
somebody give a breech birth right but
now it was just it was so it was so
primitive and it was so important to
them and I was like it's a game you guys
not no no this is the one thing I'm
doing my entire life
yeah cheering for the Saints and is
something about it and that was also a
really special year so that was like
coming back from floods yeah everything
and Drew Brees I went to Purdue and
that's in that's in India yeah yeah so
they had a little bit of that in there
did you play football at Purdue and
Georgetown I did but I'm not like you
know barely you know I'm not a huge
athlete were you were that was the
league segregated then the league
wouldn't mean the league well you mean
like you played what I'm not I didn't
grew up in the 60s
did they have leather helmets but you're
not Jim Crowe who would you were playing
[Laughter]
football when you were playing yes dude
imagine how scary it was whenever like
they first allowed like if you're a
white guy you're like all [ __ ] brother
this could be a tough year because they
were good I mean immediately you knew
those guys were gonna be better than you
and they had a chip on their shoulder oh
yeah no you know like my high school had
a hundred see there's me my high school
that's that's amazing that was yes
there was my high school 120 students
the year before they we went undefeated
like we would beat schools that had like
three thousand students and it was like
all these brothers so like me and my
brother were like the defensive ends and
like I was the tight end and he was you
know it's like a coach it was no but it
was and it wasn't like eight-man
football which they have in some parts
yeah it was it was like a full team
that's awesome was it fun it was amazing
but it was also then when I got to
college I was like this is same for me
well yeah it's just like you go to like
two-a-day practices you go to that
morning practice and everyone's coming
back always like you know like going
it's like August what am i doing what am
i doing on that I know what am I trying
to be you're just kind of brainwashed
into playing I mean I really for a
couple years I didn't watch it but now I
love it yeah well let's get into some
rounds huh all right here we go we got a
good we got some good matchups here
today you're the and but the film will
be I don't want to not talk about it
so I'll just want to give just a couple
of man it was I really got into it oh
you know I'm a I would say maybe thirty
five minutes into it and I am into the
movie girl and movies you're like what's
going on here but it seemed very
seamless no it gets it gets good it gets
good were you um worried was it how much
do you have to trust a director oh you
gotta trust them completely what's
amazing about that movie is so like I
play this guy who's a rideshare drivers
like uber and I'm on you know I've had
some bad luck divorced and so the only
way I can make money is you know he's
like those rideshare drivers they don't
do that well it can be brutal and so
then this drug dealer offers me he's he
offers me like $200 a day to be his man
to be his man
and so I reluctantly do that and then
eventually it's it does it's a little
bit about and so then my character does
some shady things and it's you know
depending on how you look at the movie
it can be kind of about entitlement and
also about like class you know like this
guy's like I'm from the middle class I
should be in the middle class but the
reality is is he you know he's isn't
fair and his choices he making her kind
of keeping him where he is it seems yes
yeah and he's got mental problems yeah
so and we say him but I mean me yeah
it's hard to take time off a touring
because financially it doesn't always
make sense to no it doesn't make there's
no money in acting yeah but but it's fun
it's rewarding you know my wife she a
couple years ago she had this medical
emergency so we made it through that and
so then you know once things kind of got
back on track I was like alright I'm
gonna do this stuff you know
I mean she's not thrilled that I'm gone
so much but you know it's a give and
take you know it's weird you know it's
like you go through moments where you're
like you know I understand the most
important thing I will do is raise my
children but I also you know doing
stand-up is really fulfilling for me
right you know coming up with a new joke
or making a story work it's hard to
articulate to people that is our heroine
you know wanted to make us feel so good
you think I think it's I think creative
people need to create something it's
like I mean comedians there's nothing
normal about us going on stage of making
strangers laugh but if we can create a
line or a joke it's like if we win
somehow yeah maybe when or just kind of
create create something you know like
just like a creative person who maybe
makes a wooden shirt yeah yeah I mean
it's like you've brought something in
big Lance said that boy's dad's name
Lancelot was the father's full name but
I also have a theory that all comedians
have strange kind of identity issues
here I mean like there's something about
you know it's like I grew up middle
class but you know it's like I you know
there's like I romanticize the you know
you know like you see guys on Long
Island or you see people you see it in
LA all the time people are like oh
that's the most la person ever and you
find out they're from Omaha yeah sure I
mean but I think that like creative
people are kind of like finding an
identity like growing up as this kind of
pale awkward kid I just was looking for
an adjective before pale hmm so it's
funny pale kid yeah I mean so but I
think comedians have there's also kind
of like the gamble behind it it's like
why do we go on stage like there's no
guarantees mm-hmm I could really relate
to the fighters the other night in a lot
of ways Oh interesting because they
worked so hard I mean they wait my buddy
was waiting six months to get this fight
you know and so just pining over this
one kind of moment and then it's not
knowing if he if he doesn't win it then
he's still a fighter and he's still a
great fighter but the the accolade isn't
there and there's focusing on that prize
to Riya and there's you know there's a
self-destructive streak in everyone yeah
I feel that sometimes too I feel that a
lot sometimes you're like what are we
doing why are we doing this and we can
see it in our friends we just can't see
it in ourselves
you're like he see a friend like by the
way we started off talking about greg
Giraldo greg Giraldo was he got a
scholarship to go to a private school in
New York City his he got a scholarship
to go to Columbia Wow he got a
scholarship to go to Harvard Law he
worked for like one of the best law
firms like when I met him he was like
the logical one and I was kind of like
dealing with anger and he was like he
was the one that got me and
like stage time in different places but
you know it's like the combination of
rejection and you know self-sabotage
this guy who had only won at life every
step of the way he wanted to lose it
sounds like he wanted more risk well I
think it's it's I think it's you know I
have my own theory I think it's like the
thing about comedians is like we've
eaten so much [ __ ] and that can make us
kind of very temperamental but you have
to have an appetite for it whereas like
people that have skated through life and
everything works you know like they get
into the college they want to do they
get their job they want they get the
girl they want it
I think and then when they deal with
disappointment disappointment they're
less prepared for I don't know this is
just my theory whereas like I think you
have to have not an appetite for failure
but kind of like oh yeah
do you I mean like we you don't want
having some on your plate yeah you know
you go up you're like this is really
funny I'm gonna try this and it doesn't
work you're like oh yeah I remember what
that or like you something you say
something wrong and it just sounds
sexist nearly that's not what I meant
but all right I'll take the pain yeah
cuz you know what that's not what I
meant but you know yeah there is
something we I get I do get a value out
of disruption somehow yeah yeah whether
the disruption is positive or negative
there's there's a reward I just realized
that in disruption like in some
disruption it's so funny because I don't
know that I remember I cuz I'm on
Instagram and Twitter and I'm always
posting shows and stuff like that and
then you know like the comedians were
like this Brotherhood and sisterhood say
you know some people now we're buddies
right
and so this was another comedian he's
like why are you touring all the time
like I just try to get my dad to say it
like I mean it's just like I don't know
maybe it's that der I mean who knows
it's not like you know
I don't think my dad disliked me but
it's like you know right like what it's
funny of work to be done like what are
you seeking yeah what is this what is it
yeah I don't know by the way I you know
people hated this movie mother but I
love that movie mother I haven't seen it
it's it's here Aronofsky no and it's
about this guy and how creative
insatiability and narcissism are just
tied together and people hate the movie
but I watched it and I was like oh my
god you could relate to it you think
it's someone yeah I think so cuz it's
like an imagined that I mean I could
imagine that I could didn't you
intellectually think alright you know
like you've got this incredibly
successful podcast why do you why do you
need more right why do you need more you
know you're you're you've got a good
life
but you you know you're kind of like I'm
curious I think you know I'm curious and
uh but yeah I wonder how much of it what
hidden even hidden narcissism czar
inside of myself that I can't find I
think about that a lot do you feel
narcissistic oh I know that there's some
of that there but yeah you know there's
I mean I'm older I've done a lot of this
is even narcissistic but I've done some
work so like I know some of the you know
I know some of the insanity I know some
of the the narcissism but I almost feel
like being a parent is kind of like that
strips a lot of that away it's like you
have to like when someone's when you
hear a baby crying you have to like get
up and do something yeah or make your
wife do it yeah Jim that's not funny
oh I thought it was really good I
thought it was really good and it's okay
man the pendulum swinging back where
people are certain understand that jokes
are jokes I think so oh so quickly to
and with a [ __ ] beautiful vengeance
man even when we have a lot of leverage
so called the king in the sting too and
it's a bower it's not my show I'm part
of a show that's called the king in the
sting and it's a little bit more just
guy humor kind of yeah and a lot of our
fans are women and they love it you know
it'sit's about intention to write yeah
and people are recognizing that so
quickly
people are going away from like you know
just the links and the you know the
clickbait you know it's just uh it's
almost run its course which in some ways
I think it's kind of a beautiful thing
you know I I hope you're right because
it's it's it's interesting because my
stand-up is not you know people are like
oh you don't talk about politics or you
don't do super filthy jokes but some of
it is it's not that I don't enjoy those
right it just doesn't come out like I
think comedians do they get a lot of
credit and criticism for the stand-up
they would do anyway hmm like you're a
great storyteller and you're like but
that's what you do do you remain right
so exactly people are like oh my gosh
you do thank God you do food jokes I'm
like look if I could write jokes about
other stuff and and and I have but like
there is something of like you don't
like the whole joke I always say is when
people like I love the fact that you're
you don't curse and you're stand up I'm
like well Jesus won't let me here I mean
it's like it's it's not as if I don't
curse in everyday life but but it's also
what way it's like you for me I find I
become an instrument and it's like what
way do I like to play this instrument
the best that I am or what way do i
model I'm still learning a lot about
whatever instrument I am but there's
ways that I know that I like to play it
the best that it feels the most
comfortable in I'm on the stage and I
feel like I can get a reaction out of
people that is a reaction that I want to
get out of them like you know I used to
go for a lot more a little bit more edgy
and I was trying to prove something to
myself but now I really want to I want
to play the instrument the best I can I
want to take care of my instrument and I
want to play it for people the best way
that gets a good that gets the best
reaction sometimes I'm telling jokes I
don't maybe really want to tell that
much but I know that they're gonna like
it you know well I think stand-up is
such a self-assignment to it's like you
you know there's no boss that says now
you should do this or that
look there's there's jokes that I've
done were now do the juggling you know
no no well there's jokes where I like I
have this joke about that
McDonald's which was all about figuring
out a way because I was so kind of angry
about how there was this judgment like
you know like you know like mainstream
oh that's so mainstream like why is that
bad it's not do you remain like why is
you know it's like someone eating
McDonald's that's not it's for the end
of the world yeah you know I mean and so
like the anger surrounding that made me
give the assignment like I got to come
up with something that can articulate
that mmm and so that was you know kind
of that's McDonald so that's like
everyone has their guilty pleasures so
let's not be condescending yeah and so
like the self assignment stuff is great
you know and I don't know what you know
it's like every now and then you just
set assignments you're like you know
what I'm gonna do something I want to
talk about this right what a you know
what a you know we're so lucky that we
get to do that that's yeah same yeah I'm
just getting to that point I've just
realized the other day once I got
minimum wage and it's just been kind of
just thing in the sense keeps coming up
in my head when I wake up in the morning
I don't know what I'm gonna say about it
I don't know what story I'll tell that I
relate out of my own life but I know I
believe that eventually now kind of
knowing a little bit my own process that
I'll come up with something you know it
kind of talks about it in some way this
past weekend is brought to you by skill
share and we're thankful for that you
know look a lot of times you see
somebody with a sword and they don't
even know what they're doing they're
trying to grill a weenie on it over a
fire or to make a mushroom and for the
s'mores
dude that's a sword learn how to use it
learn a skill skill share is an online
learning community for creators or
creators with more than 25,000 classes
and design business and more you'll
discover countless ways to fuel your
curiosity creativity and career take
classes in social media marketing mobile
photography creative writing or even
illustration whether you're looking to
discover a new passion start a sod
hustle or gain new professional skills
skill share is there to keep you learn
have a child that doesn't know something
put his little ass in front of
Skillshare join the millions of students
already learning on Skillshare today
with a special offer support our podcast
get two months of Skillshare for three
that's right Skillshare is offering this
past weekend listeners two months of
unlimited access to over 25,000 classes
for free go to Skillshare comm slash
Theo von again go to Skillshare dot-com
slash Theo von to start your two months
now that Skillshare dot-com slash Theo
von let's get into some of these wars
because I know these guys are excited
okay and uh and Nick's gonna take us
through a couple of battles here I don't
care don't blame us that we could listen
or the conversation all day but yeah we
are in the Midwest we're in the round of
the sweet 16
we're gonna start with the number seven
Iowa verse number three Michigan and
we've got a couple entries from fans top
CEO Jim this Mitch from Iowa City Iowa I
think war because we have countless I'm
at a very unique guy or because we have
countless amount of people you wouldn't
expect to be from Iowa first of all we
got John Wayne and ultimate badass
we got Aquaman Jason Momoa is from Iowa
we got Superman Brenner of routes from
Iowa plus we got all wrestlers deer
hunters and MMA fighters from Iowa
that's basically practice for a war if
you're asking me Plus after we're done
fighting you know our losses in Iowa
Bridges of Madison County Theo I know
you love that so I have to like them
whooping up on I've never seen you know
what I think I rave a wife that's insane
I read the book you know what it's word
my wife's not 70 yeah well your wife has
a [ __ ] heartbeat and I'll say this bro
that the Wits word-for-word from the
book it's the exact oh really oh it's so
good man so you've kind of seen it if
you have an imagination while you're
reading by the way great points us go
ahead yeah Ryan and that's Iowa and
they're there did ebony for Michigan we
do let's see what we got here
there's in counterpoint you know what a
feel first off just wants a man been
killing the game digging the pot
for sure hang so we got this Iowa
Michigan lineup dude not even a
competition
Michigan's got this hands down bro Iowa
it's just a big cornfield how you
supposed to organize when he getting
lost walking out of your front door dude
I've seen children of the corn I've seen
signs once you do get organized you got
to worry about kids killing you you got
to worry about aliens abducting you
that's a lot more to worry about than
just a war but Michigan we've got two
armies we've got the LP the Lower
Peninsula the good old boys where the
factors are at the guns are at then you
start moving up north
you got the you pee the you proced nah
man these people are different up there
they're crazy
it's winter year-round I don't didn't go
up there man I'm scared dude he's good
they're riding the wolves they're
jousting off moves yeah I should not
talk over at the house that guy riding
movies are jealous ting he said some up
monkeys at the end well he brings up a
really interesting point there's two
pieces of Michigan hmm right like I
don't know what Wisconsin did wrong to
not get the Upper Peninsula but it's not
even really connected and the Yoopers
are no joke right it is so they've got
some they've got they've got urban
mm-hmm Michigan's got Detroit which is
like great place to get beat up and buy
a house for $2 yeah great faces start a
pact to starting fires a great place
they have factories old factories that
could immediately we brought this up in
the last round be be refurbished to to
create more it would be needed and you
know your dad Kid Rock is from their
appointed and so there is like there's
there's the there's a you know like
there's Motown there's a lot of music
there oh yeah I think Bob's is Bob Seger
from there Wisconsin Jeff Daniels is
from Michigan from Michigan you have
okay but let's say it let's talk about
life flakes that's
that's Battle Creek Battle Creek
Michigan Rapids Detroit for Bob Seger is
right it's you know bon jovi or they
know they need you he's Jersey am i did
my gran my mom was born in Iowa my
grandfather it's not my number the woods
College in Iowa Copiah Lincoln actually
: College if you're from otra heard of
that or not a very bad school no it's
not bad it's very small um you know that
haircutting it's their thing in
population-wise Michigan must Trump it
it's just there's not that many people
in Iowa Michigan a lot of dis a lot of
people collecting disability in Michigan
a lot of people 10 million in Michigan 3
million in Iowa that's I don't you know
like there is a resourcefulness
there isn't a unifying thing there's a
lot of different types of people in
Michigan but that means they can fight
like we're literally talking like wars
between these two states but we have to
talk about it Jim I think it's just a
population just makes it incredibly
unlikely that they would be able to
defeat them now you're probably who's
gonna do mission if manufacturing
Michigan has manufacturing before the
remnants of it right they could switch
and turn you know some of those old car
plants into making bullets yeah or bows
and arrows yeah that's a good point and
I would have they're gonna be able to
eat though I was gonna be able to
survive for sustenance but I think you
know out of necessity with the weapons
when Michigan comes down I think I would
go Michigan on this what do you guys
think yeah I think Michigan
I think they they've got a resilience
they lasted through the recession and
they're still there and they're
rebuilding so I think it's gonna be well
it's not like there would get rid of the
sate right it's well you know what you
guys have to be northern Ohio now Canada
could have taken it Oh Michigan
Michigan's 71% our listeners voted how
many votes do we have net 9,500 but that
was only half a day so that's pretty
impressed well yeah I would say that
Iowa
very impressive state
very impressive there's there's uh oh
great people yeah a lot of MIDI but
there's there's also like this hard
scrabble kind of you know it's like the
they're still towns but I mean like
there's towns and Cedar Rapids I've been
to I've been all around abused awesome
there's just there they're there they're
tough tough people yeah well he said
that gentleman said they got wrestlers
up there oh yeah corn corn guys great
wrestlers AIA and Oklahoma great
wrestlers syrup syrup I don't know if
they have syrup corn they gots her up
day they got Cyril I got corn sir you
know what Iowa has is I was big on pork
yeah
a lot of pork pork bellies did the Iowa
Fair open for a NASCAR it wasn't that
there was a NASCAR driver wasn't there
open for just the car pushed down again
I talked about stand up and people were
more excited about the car
Jean Reeve has a good joke he was at a
Holiday Inn or somewhere after a show
right after he was on you know Jon REEP
is yeah right after he was on a
America's Got Talent
Last Comic Standing and he was in the
lobbying is late at night and some lady
he was like in the final three and he
was pulling on the road that weekend and
the show was still in TV and the ladies
like so did you win it and he's like
well I can't tell you what well I can't
tell you what happened but I can and she
goes no did you win it he's like what
she's like the bass boat in the lobby
the one there doing the drawing for just
such a funny moment I don't know why I
told you that but I'll go Michigan on
this you guys have any other thoughts I
agree I was a great place a lot of
wrestlers a lot of tough tough guys
coming out of there but I think when you
get to the weaponry it's the same thing
that beat out the Native Americans they
showed up with weapons and you know
smoke you can only blow some smoke ins
people's faces so many so many times I'm
so the I think the internet was invented
at University of Michigan so there's
some technology there there you go and
my tea is there dude MIT Michigan
Institute of Technology yep the MIT is
Massachusetts Institute of Technology or
that's theirs right okay all right
Michigan takes it Wow Michigan takes our
first elite 18 and now Jim's home state
Indiana first the number one seed in the
Midwest Illinois I mean I I you know
look population wise there's no
comparison I have to I was born in
Illinois oh really now we're going down
to the gazai goat I conceived that
that's what I want to know oh yeah
busted probably Illinois one of my
Kewanee Peoria it was no it was a Elgin
Illinois I was the only one of the six
kids that was born in the Midwest they
were all born in Brooklyn hmm I would
say it's gotta be I mean first of all
just the amount of guns in Chicago yeah
right all right but here we should see
what these guys have he's your buddy hey
Theo it's ouch from Indiana weighing in
on Indiana versus Illinois a man India
would definitely kick their ass we have
peyton manning to lead us to victory
we have Purdue University one of the
best public schools in the country
pumping out engineers new vehicles new
weapons we have all the stupid kids from
Indiana University they'll just follow
any orders we give them plus we have
Gary okay bye okay and that's true and
Bloomington Indiana is like that it's
like where a lot of kids go because they
didn't make it into an Ivy League school
and their parents in America Billy's
interesting you know yeah there's a lot
of creative like I went to Purdue for a
year and Purdue was like if you were
like I don't want my kid I don't want my
daughter to get pregnant I'll send her
to Purdue yeah but don't they called it
it was an engineering school too but as
a good point a lot of Engineers some
good points there it's interesting
because when I was growing up in Indiana
there was a lot of self net self hatred
but like we're in the anti sorry you
know it was like it was not the state
pride that was diss
blade there hmm it was much more of you
know you travel around and sometimes
people are like thank you for coming
here yeah and there's some places where
they never think of that do you I mean
like Northern California they're like
you're lucky to be here yeah dear I mean
whereas like but Indiana was like you
know we're Indiana like it when I was a
teenager like me and my friends were
like we got to get out now I love it
yeah but it'll be interesting to see
what this Illinois guy yeah cuz I
champion I really love the Midwest and I
think I feel like there's a lot of pride
there these days maybe yeah maybe it's
changing what's what's this guy got if
you know this is Danny from Chicago I'm
weighing in on Indiana versus Illinois
and I want to throw a quick set out
there for you guys from 2001 to 2016
there's actually been more murders in
Chicago than there has been in the Iraq
and the Afghanistan war Wow this was
actually a BBC report a couple years ago
and Wool if you think about that we're
not only gonna take Indiana but we're
also gonna take the entire bracket so I
got Illinois in this one and run it off
of the entire bracket Gang Gang there
you go
huh I mean he does make a point it's
like I could see a reason why Illinois
could run the whole table but are those
gang because a lot of Lynn look let's be
realistic about Chicago a lot of they're
murdering it's not all over the city
it's in a couple of areas it's very I
don't even say quarantine but it really
is like even when I'm there people say
look Chicago is a safe place to be
there's a couple like you know there's a
quarter-mile a half quarter mile or
something square that's very dangerous
now is that group gonna work with others
you know whenever things get going is
Indiana gonna work together or some of
those people gonna leave and join
Michigan all you do have Bobby Knight
the general he could lead the troops
he's originally from Ohio but I think I
think that Crimson runs deep oh yeah
he's got crimson spots on his arms I
think there is something
about I mean Indianapolis is a great
city by the way oh yeah great city I
don't know I say think like I just think
popular look let's look at the
population it's dramatic like that's
that's what influenced Michigan versus
Iowa so it's like twelve point seven
million for Illinois and six point seven
million for Indiana okay a lot more than
I thought
in Indiana yeah a lot more than I
thought a lot of [ __ ] over there um
that's the bus belt dude a lot of people
busted out there and growing it up I you
know I don't know I I think I have to I
have to defer here because it's like I
grew up in Northwest Indiana so I should
pick Indiana but I also intellectually
think Chicago with like Chicago
I mean Illinois is like it's by the way
that is some Midwest stuff oh yeah yeah
I mean like you go to like Western
Illinois it goes on forever oh yeah here
I mean you're like we're still in
Illinois and then Springfield
Bloomington Illinois it's like but I
don't know I mean it's it's a romantic
thing I think Indiana that would be it
would be fun you know it's like the
movie Hoosiers what if they win the
whole table Jimmy Chitwood do the picket
fence you know I'm saying something
could happen what let's go up to the
twink nation let's get Gianni what do
you think brother I love an underdog so
I'm gonna go with Indiana Wow mm-hmm and
I like me I like I've been in Indiana in
Illinois and I liked Indiana better oh
my god I think Indiana
even though Illinois has 4 million more
people Indiana they seem to you said
they didn't have pride back in the day
since their basketball teams been good
they seem like they're always on the
same page they have assembly hall so
they can all assemble there
Gary's just Chicago Southside Chicago
jr. so I like Indiana I mean we should
also say that Wisconsin they they kind
of hate Chicago like there's a little
bit of like any message so well there's
a little bit of you know the younger
brother thing by the way you even go to
Minneapolis
and they're like we know we're not
Chicago you don't have to be Chicago
yeah
your Minneapolis your great city
Madison's a great city
Milwaukee's a great city it's a you
don't have to be Chicago people are
gonna want to see Chicago fall I think
it's opposite though I think Chicago has
the chip on its shoulder and they like
they don't want to be Midwest they want
to be known as a city so they're all
kind of [ __ ] they're kind of like
the outlier so I don't think the rest of
the state would would hop on to help
Chicago or vice-versa and I feel like a
lot of people aren't from Chicago who
moved there so they're just gonna go
home back to their own state and fight
for them so I feel like they lose a lot
of their numbers hey you got a ton of
Blackhawks fans you have a lot of I mean
you have the nurses down there
Bloomington a lot it's a nursing school
you got the Salukis of southern Illinois
Salukis you got by the way you know the
Blackhawks
that was actually an Iowa thing mmm
Black Hawk the the Indian general was
from Iowa and he went he went to Iowa he
went to Chicago he went to Chicago he
went to Chicago he but you know what if
it came down to Chicago versus Illinois
I mean versus Iowa would they merge to
fight Michigan I mean we could have that
happen I don't I want to see one of
these ones he's go down I like what what
did the fans say they say it's such a
tough one here just population wise
twice as much Illinois I think I up for
me I have to go with Illinois on this I
you know I like Indiana I think it's on
the come-up I just don't know if their
organization's gonna be enough to take
it'll annoy right I don't know if I mean
you know as one uh I don't think I
realistically I should be able to vote
because I have to vote for my home state
but I also have shows this September in
Illinois yeah you were I was born there
great I can't I can't do it but like by
the way even being a Colts fan being
from Northwest Indiana big betrayal big
betrayal for a lot of Chicago people how
dare you yeah not be a Bears fan so and
then I married a girl from Wisconsin so
I like the pack
so it's like my brothers like what the
what is it going home yeah you might be
having some real low you know some
regional issues yeah
Illinois all right you know all the ones
all the one seeds still remaining
alright moving on to the West we got
number seven New Mexico versus number
six Utah a couple Cinderella's Wow
is it is that cholera what is the colors
Hannah
Carla Tana oh that's Colorado and
Montana combined
yeah they decided to merge oh that's
interesting that'll happen oh yeah
I don't happen do they geographically
even connect no they don't right but
they figured it out yeah cuz this it was
second round so the second figure
yeah the debate went too long we just
couldn't figure it out what do you guys
think here New Mexico have any bids for
these guys yes New Mexico and Utah it's
it's Utah beyond a doubt it's Utah the
organization you know they it's all
I'm originally from California but I've
been out here for 13 years so I
definitely know the Mormon culture and
they are so efficient oh my goodness
they give ten percent of their income to
the church so they have a lot of money
they also follow all the rules they
three kids are probably don't like my
kids have no one to play with on Sundays
and they follow that regimented and they
also have to have food storage they have
to have at least yours worth down in
their basement like it is a mandatory
havin if guns down there and they are
they're efficient as for New Mexico I
don't know what scream chillers amazing
they are good somebody's got a ski was
an Albuquerque we're just at the end if
she was mentioning how chris d'elia
gotten some trouble for tweeting about
Albuquerque you said it sucked and it
was on the news and made the local news
are you serious like comedian Chris
D'Elia desired what yeah I want to see
that that's hilarious
that's so weird cause like by the way
when I was in Albuquerque like I mean
granted Alma picked but the green
Chili's yeah that is they're supposed to
be good good afternoon
Albuquerque has been a punching bag for
a few celebrities as they've made their
way through town the latest a well-known
comedian who bashed the city after
playing at a city-owned treasure the
Kimo News 13s Rebecca Adkins is live
there with what he said and how people
are responding Rebecca well came
according to ticket sales this is where
Chris D'Elia performed at last Thursday
but while he was here he had some sort
of a bad experience
soon after chris d'elia is a big name in
the comedy world and Thursday night he
performed at the Kimo theater
I know I look like a tired eagle I don't
like how you laughed at dad to be honest
it was his second time in Albuquerque
but something on this visit left a bad
taste in his mouth
after his performance downtown he took
to Twitter to take a jab at Albuquerque
saying I've been to some blank holes but
holy God you make Jacksonville look like
paradise retweeted almost 600 times
people we spoke to weren't too happy
about what he said and on Twitter people
had mixed feelings
this person listed off Albuquerque
staples like green chile and the
Sandia's and said what more could you
want others agreed with D'Elia
with one person saying they're from here
and should be offended but then said
you're right hashtag past the met
hilarious that is unbelievable I might
just ride with Dahlia right out of the
gate then is there is there any videos
we need to see you think named I I think
we should move it along okay we'll take
Utah then on this round then you good
with that yeah yeah that's fine I think
this is the yeah by the way but New
Mexico is amazing it's so funny it's so
funny how like it was just a tweet then
cut out there it's like a five-minute
busy and I disagree and I'll probably be
there sometime this year as well but he
did tweet out later as they mentioned at
the end of the piece that Santa Fe is
beautiful though you know I you know
great yeah
all right here we are okay all right we
really need some input here what do we
have we have anything video was yeah
let's do one for Collett Anna what's up
California versus Cholet Anna I'm just
gonna say I live in California but I
totally believe Colorado and Montana
would win here's why because everyone in
California
so soft and did they have the pollution
on their hands before they even take a
piss also have you ever hung out with
anyone from Colorado Montana their idea
of fun is going and shooting an elk
hollowing it out living in it for three
days and hotboxing it now in California
their favorite activity is waiting in
line for 4 hours for avocado toast it's
no contest
also the only way only way California
would win is if they were to move to
Colorado and Montana and gentrify their
neighborhoods and then push everyone out
so they couldn't afford it game game
game brother um look it's a population
wise it's just by the book uh yeah I
mean it's it's you know in California
itself is the fifth largest economy in
the world but a lot of people are gonna
find a lot of people gonna hit their
knees and pray a lot of people are gonna
defecate to their original countries and
have you ever seen 300 oh yeah Russell
army you think Russell Brand is gonna be
able to defeat everybody all right he's
with California oh yeah I don't even
know no but people are most people gonna
defecate to their original countries and
they're not gonna have the you're not
gonna have you know I don't think you're
gonna have a lot of middle so much
wealth I could hire mercenaries it's
California sorry guys do here's somebody
else is about filling you Colin reppin
for Cali California versus called Tana
handful of reasons why kasi weep that
ass number one forty million population
I ain't even got a say more than that
Trump's Colorado and Montana by far
here's the main reason all we got to do
send the essays up north and send South
Central Crips Bloods essays all we need
gang gang
Kylie wins all the way do you two-man
gang brother thank you for hitting us up
brother man I'm gonna say this I don't
think a bunch of Mexican and black guys
if something's gonna go fight for a
bunch of white people like I don't know
if I seed
I mean and maybe he's not saying that
and I'm not saying that he is but you
know are you gonna get are you gonna get
yeah
the Crips might go fight I think we're
gonna kill their mercenaries there you
know there might be money there
motivating it yeah but forget all that
Google money now what about the water I
think a lot of water comes down from
dinner if they shut that down so that
they can't even get water down here then
that's really gonna change the that's
gonna change a lot of the land's gear
didn't matter what we call a channel in
this man call it Tanner I love it I love
it Montana was my dark horse from the
beginning and they're still kicking and
Dark Horse is not a racial slur what do
you guys think
gianni I'm still gonna go with
California even though I think la is
really soft I mean you got Oakland you
got stock Stockton you got San
Bernardino like there's some tough
cities in California yeah yeah I think
these heart these large populations
they're hard to galvanize though it
presents just as many problems as it is
an advantage like it's hard to get
everybody on the same page that's a good
point
if you think the guys in San Bernardino
San Bernardino we're gonna go fight for
frickin Larry Hollywood and frickin you
know it's the guys name they're not
gonna put they're not gonna do it you
know they're not gonna do it for Larry
Hollywood uh-uh
down the old classic Larry Hollywood or
Bob Santa Monica or Suzie Beverly you
know she's done there she's done or
Belinda Carlisle good so what do we have
here named all right think Altana
advance the number one overall seed goes
down Wow Wow that's amazing it's
incredible
let's hit two more and then we're all at
a rap that sound good for yeah sure okay
so we got West Virginia number seven in
the East verse number three New Jersey
let's see New Jersey Wow
gang gang to you what's good Tyler
Renee here from Jersey and no time for
America Jersey would absolutely
hahahaha West Virginia up we throw a
pack of like natty light over to the
left come with a swift
punch haymaker right to the faces dude
it wouldn't be able to handle it they
don't know how to wrestle down in West
Virginia you know we know how to wrestle
up here um and they don't just I don't
know they just [ __ ] live in the
mountains and [ __ ] and like we got to
survive like fight [ __ ] and
[ __ ] like Jersey City Newark bro come on
you know you know what the airport in
brother
layover just got no Newark is a tough
city oh it's a legendary Alito said a
lot of bullets over there um West's
virginity the West Virginia video what
if like the guy in West Virginia has a
shirt on and the guy in Jersey might do
it right there textiles well the it's
interesting maybe they're preparing for
war already but West Virginia is the
only state this round we didn't get a
video for us so they're not showing out
or you might have fizzled out they've
been through a lot already they had to
battle Vermont they had a battle
Pennsylvania that they beat that and
that was it that was a tough matchup
there's yeah well you know if they can't
submit a video I don't see how they can
get the truth then I watch is there as
two white trash guys yeah it's in West
Virginia kind of like why treasure to
also refer to myself as white treasure
is it isn't West Virginia kind of it's
the Jerusalem of white trash I mean it's
definitely more this you know it's a
it's the vowel belt that's what I call
it not a lot of get wheezing consonants
over there you know a I know and it
touches what I love about West Virginia
as it touches everywhere like you'll be
like its burg DC you know net wheeling
feeling Albuquerque may like you know
West Virginia right they're like is it
its geography it goes everywhere like a
spider that's the hills man West
Virginia I like how you said the
Jerusalem of white trash have you ever
seen the wonderful whites of West
Virginia yeah beautiful I did a movie
where I played a part of a guy who was
part of a cult that believed in snake
healing and I had a great beard but I
loved it we shot it in Ohio you did but
but you played it off as West Virginia
Western unions have been through a lot
New Jersey
[Music]
New Jersey huge population yeah you may
got milk
they got fresh milk very tough Jersey
people are tough I'll go with Jersey
then I'll go with Jersey yeah you think
yeah I think Jersey I say we blow
through these last three we can get to
the elite 8 ok let's do it then
Massachusetts versus in New York I think
I'm live in New York and it let's just
do New York because it'll anger people
in New England Wow
I agree look Julian Edelman just retired
so I think you're gonna have to go New
York you know Tom Brady's getting old
Rob Gronkowski Rob Gronkowski just
retired today you got oh just anger
people people are not gonna be happy
about no they're not gonna be happy and
we're just doing that to get your your
replies up and blame gym guys because I
would have thought it out a little bit
more put that New Jersey New York
matchup that's a dream matchup so I'm
glad we got that's gonna be a big
another Florida Georgia line which is a
band we could make them that we could
merge them and do those two we have some
videos yeah who do you think Florida
Georgia line would fight for I don't
know I never really read who don't mind
this but I barely read who Florida's
facing I live in New York City now
because I had to get the [ __ ] out of
Florida strictly because I think
Florida's gonna win in any matchup
because of [ __ ] alligators do it
alligators crazy people no matter who
George is Georgia I don't know I'm kind
of drunk I'm out but no matter if right
now is facing Florida is they're gonna
lose to Florida because of
methamphetamines crocodiles its heat a
lot of hot a lot of hot [ __ ] going on
there's just a bunch there's a bunch
happening in Florida that is ok I might
be doing drugs
yeah you have another video from Georgia
yeah unbelievable guy what's up Theo
this is Daniel from Rome Georgia and I
think Georgia Bates Florida because
number one Georgia on my mind
Ray Charles number two not as crazy I'm
yes in war Florida you know could be a
little crazy it's like kamikaze you know
that's what I'm thinking of
but Georgia we got some good heads in
the game how much a gallery people from
Georgia Tech we got some good football
players over at UGA you know we're good
at being second place so I figured you
know if we get later in the in the round
will probably come in second and that's
just the reality but yeah go Dawgs Gang
Gang Gang Gang brother neither of those
guys get very come on yeah very not a
lot of compelling argument out of there
no what do you think Jim they got citrus
over this and no scurvy you're not got a
lot of scurvy in Florida but Georgia's
got peaches you can have a lot of
cobbler cobbler I'll slow a man down
wanted him I know you know I would
rather I would rather have the barbecue
in Georgia how much cobbler you had
honestly in one city I'm not a huge
cobbler guy I just you know I know it's
German chocolate cake have you ever had
one time German chocolate cake I did
that that's the what about I like red
velvet do you really yeah you don't like
it I mean I just never would have
thought that about you
yeah well you know I'm gonna go out on a
limb I might lose people here Florida
Georgia it's how much key lime pie view
ad be honest though it's key lime pie
it's good but it's a little sour right
yes sour milk that's why it's good right
yeah it's lime it's lime I'm gonna say
look whoever it is whoever wins this is
gonna lose to Texas in the next round
anyway okay so pick who you are Oh
unless they did Florida juh Florida
Jackson Lord could could compete with
that Strickler doja I'll go Florida yeah
Florida Joe can we do flora Jeanette
yeah but do people vote anywhere I'm
curious to see that I bet that that was
pretty close 59% said Florida and they
do have a bigger population so that is
pretty close for I'll go Florida yeah
Florida yeah yeah
basically Florida jeah I think right is
good flora Jia will take it all right
Wow
I like floored uh Gee I don't you yeah
Florida please put the D in there and
that's the difference between that's
what a comedian does yeah
that's that some of the skills that we
bring yeah thank you by the way so a lot
of history in Virginia a lot of war
heroes in Virginia a huge state but
Texas is Texas we filmed your movie
though isn't it it is and there's a lot
there's a lot of different Virginia's
true there's a lot of different
Virginia's military Virginia there's um
kind of a black history Virginia they
got the Navy they're Hollywood Cemetery
they have one of the oldest cemeteries
as there's eight presidents buried in it
let's see what this gentleman had to say
this is one of my favorite submissions
all right Rowan Saints yooka-laylee
Virginia and guess what they're really
racist ethic tiki torches far from new
jersey yes that is very true I am a
half-black half-italian too we have a
huge naval base that was that a tune but
we got this CIA we know what to do so
guess what what we not afraid of the
camera we obviously don't a lot of
people lost their jobs for Stan enough
or something stupid so when it comes to
fighting guess what's gonna happen
people like me we're Air Force Ones are
gonna step out to the side with all
these country people that have no
freakin sense I like to hunt squirrels
I'm gonna step up do what they got to do
with all them guns and Navy SEALs and
ships and navy and body bing-bang-boom
we went he was stoned right what was he
saying at the end he trailed off he
could be a politician you know I think
that was Ocasio Cortez
right there I think that that was oh you
know he does bring up the
Charlottesville thing like there is some
the some of that history it could be a
problem there whereas Texas
I feel like Texas is a whole other
country I think if there is a unifying
force in Texas agreed agreed let's see
what this gentleman has right here yo
what's up do I don't know who taxes up
against I don't know if it really
matters we got we we try to secede long
ago Rick Perry was already on this [ __ ]
trying to secede we could have done it
throw a session to talk to us 2008 oh
when was that
the other Texas baby and then uh we have
Bonnie and Clyde Bonnie and Clyde
Charles Whitman that man is a sniper row
rest in peace to those who lost a lot
but there man to shoot and that's that
goes for everybody here bro we all got
guns all of us
brother the most liberal people got that
the Liberals
they got Glocks the Valachi over an
integral piece yeah guy with a gun
Liberace
oh really yeah well that is true
everyone in Texas has ever got bro I'm
gonna I'm gonna make this an easy for us
I'm gonna go Texas I agree Texas he said
they weren't even affected by the
recession in 2008 oh yeah no there is
some wealth there there's more people
moving into Texas every day yeah
the oil is turning into tack and they
have a much better they're blending I
think population like ethnicities and
stuff better than other places are and I
think liberal people move there become
conservative yeah I agree so that's a
that's a strong Texas has a strong
culture - yeah very front cultural wrap
what I like about Texas is it's one of
the places where you work hard you do
what you need to do and there's a little
bit of code of ethics I feel like
amongst themselves that other states
don't exactly have just within the state
like if you're a Texan you're a Texan
and if you're not then that means
something that you're something else
well the the food in Texas is amazing -
you got the tex-mex
you got the barbecue and you got the
steak oh yeah so it's like I would just
give it just for the food
oh you know did I look fatter while I
said that I tried to look fatter
actually if you may if you hold your
neck longer we say you're much better
yeah you look leaner you go have you
been working out
oh dude Texas dude they got everything's
good to eat there I'd suck a damn you
know I'd suck a the barbecue is
unbelievable let's suck a Gobstopper out
of a doves ass over there it's beautiful
man
okay who is it Nicholas let's just
rattle them off and we'll close out oh
so we're close we're taking it all the
way through no we're done oh yeah we're
down to the Elite Eight it's Michigan
versus Illinois Utah where's cal Tana
Texas first floor Florida Florida
Florida Florida jeah
gotcha and New Jersey versus New York
fun matchups right that's gonna be fun
and just the anger from the
Massachusetts folks directed at Theo
remember I wanted it to be Massachusetts
he wanted it to be New York if I
remember that part Jim I have all these
shows in Boston coming up and I'd
appreciate if no one would bring this up
is it scary want you to start doing all
the theaters like I just said met the
place now a little bit we're having some
of those opportunities to do it's
amazing some of it feels scary like I'm
gonna with alienate like some fans
because I won't get to see as many of
them in person well I think there's you
know like the thing that's so great
about theaters is that it's the setting
kind of is is kind of like nice like
people are going out it's a beautiful
theater whether it's small theater or a
big theater right people can do kind of
like there are people that wouldn't want
to go to comedy clubs that will go to
theaters there's the theater setting is
just there's not like I mean I love
comedy clubs but there is something
about like you you know everyone that's
going there knows your comedic point of
view so it's like talking to an old
friend
whereas I love comedy clubs but like you
know people don't know who's gonna be on
half the time I mean granted you're
drawing people to comedy clubs but it's
there's something fun about it
it's atmosphere kind of can make people
behave better
mm-hmm now that I could say yeah because
you sit down it feels like oh I'm here
to see something yeah you know I might
even see a president get [ __ ] shot
Yeah right
I don't know that'll happen but that
ain't happening at you know at the
Cincinnati funnybone that I was in a
theater no John Wilkes Booth ain't
hitting up you know Cincinnati had a
great comedy club in the suburbs I don't
know what happened to it oh yeah I used
to go to that place I think yeah they're
really good guys that run it but I don't
know what happened everybody that was 30
years ago he died y'all done okay
well you know him you love him uh man
what an honor and what a pleasure to
have you here today to help us get
through a couple more rounds of state
wars a-and something that will be used
probably by Don Lemon in a couple of and
a couple will darling Lemmon and Charles
Tucker whatever what's of the other guys
named Philippe Tucker some yeah uh
Carlson he goes by Philippe
yeah the white Don Lemmon those guys so
probably you know they'll use this type
of stuff in the future too terrific rate
if they ended up together right like a
romantic I hate you I hate you kiss kiss
kiss they should put him on an amazing
race team together right they're like I
don't know if they would do it Wow
but they should I would love to see an
amazing race where they put people who
were who have different political
beliefs together that would be
interesting huh isn't that what the
whole country is right now it's like we
need people feel like I think people
gotta be open to like different points
of view I love having friends that have
different points of view
oh no I learned it's easier than reading
yeah I like having friends with
different points of views it doesn't
mean I throw them out it just means you
know I'm always right yeah I think it's
getting easier now people aren't as
motivated I don't think at this point he
starting to realize okay I wasn't that
motivated about pulling some political
stuff I just want to live my life and
take care of myself and be good to other
people um Jim Gaffigan thank you so much
we got a Grammy mama we got a gift for
him tears of pleasure all gift we just
got a little gift
I actually think it's something I'll
come in handy for you too and this is a
nice charger Oh
from one of our sponsors called Ridge
and we just give it to you and uh you
can you just charge your iphone in case
something happens you're in a fire case
you're in a state and some stuff goes
down alive I love it you'll be that
power e bad boy you guys should get is
this your logo you should get your logo
on there you know the company should do
that that would be a good idea right
good idea
I bet they would which loves us yeah if
they've support us for a long time um
yeah we're Thema getting a new studio
actually up about Bowa you should do
this in your kitchen didn't you yeah
it's all good it's great well it's been
a blast I appreciate it
Thank You Man I appreciate you a big fan
of your company for so long thank you
for letting me borrow that material at
one time and I'll never do it again yeah
oh we're ready open up something man
all right thanks you guys all right
thanks
[Music]
when I reach that round I'll share this
piece of my mouth I can defeat it in my
thought it's gonna take
little town for me to slap that parking
brake can let myself
[Music]